le dieu de la mafia documentaire réalisé
par Anne veryron un film vous venez de
le voir qui s'interroge sur le lourd
silence longtemps observé au sein de
l'Église catholique à propos des crimes
mafieux qui durant des décennies ont
pourtant ensanglanté des régions
historiquement très pieuses du sud de
l'Italie l'occasion pour nous maintenant
sur ce plateau de débadoc de se demander
si l'État italien pour sa part est enfin
parvenu à marquer des points décisifs
dans sa longue L
contre les mafias et nous allons le
faire avec vous pour commencer Charlotte
moche bienvenue vous êtes historienne
maîtresse de conférence en études
italiennees à l'université Jean-Moulin
Lyon I et spécialiste du mouvement
antimafia et des mafias italienne Paolo
Levi est également avec nous bienvenue
vous êtes journaliste et correspondant à
Paris pour l'agence de presse italienne
enzaar et puis enfin fabrice rizoli est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
docteur en sciences politiques à
l'université parisen Panthéon Sorbonne
spécialiste de la grande criminalité
vous êtes par ailleurs le fondateur et
le président de l'association crimalt et
nous vous devons entre autrre la mafia
de A à Z crime organisé mafia antimfia
160 définitions pour un état des lieux
édité chez team buctu édition merci à
tous les trois de participer à ce débat
doc aujourd'hui pour bien préciser les
choses et par rapport au au film que
nous venons de voir ensemble où il est
beaucoup question de Cosanostra cette
fameuse mafia sicilienne longtemps et
beaucoup mise en avant par le cinéma
américain par Hollywood notamment à
travers les trois volets du Parin
réalisé par Francis fort copola mais pas
seulement il n'y a pas une mafia en
Italie mais plusieurs mafias et c'est un
des problèmes peut-être de l'État
italien faut faut bien le préciser pour
commencer oui alors on a trois mafias
principales qu'on va dire trois mafias
historiques qui naissent au milieu du
19e siècle donc kanstra en Sicile
landranget en Calabre la camor
dans la région de Naples donc en
Campagnie et une mafia beaucoup plus
récente qu'on appelle la Sacra Corona
Unita dans les Pouilles hein dans la
région du talon de la botte mais qui est
beaucoup plus disomogène et maintenant
la criminalité est centrée autour de la
région de forge tout cela c'est au sud
de l'Italie autrement dit ces Mafi se
sont installés dans des régions
particulièrement démunies pour ce qui
concerne la la population et ce qui
concerne l'économie locale c'est ça la
clé de la réussite et la mise en place
la main mise de ces mafias dans cette
fameuse dans ce sud de la botte
italienne alors la recherche a quand
même montré que justement les mafias
sont un facteur de modernité
c'est-à-dire elles ont réussi si elles
ne s'était euh si c'était vraiment que
la pauvreté qui avait donné vie aux
mafia les mafias seraient mortes avec le
développement économique or elles ont
continué à se développé et justement
elles ont muté pour certaines et elles
sont surtout elles se sont étend endu
c'est-à-dire que elles ont on parle
maintenant d'enracinement en dehors des
zones traditionnelles donc dans le nord
de l'Italie en particulier dans le
nord-ouest à partir des années 60 dans
toute la zone du triangle économique
donc la zone la plus dynamique du pays
donc c'est bien que les mafias sont un
facteur de qu'elles arrivent à vivre
avec cette modernité tout en ayant des
systèmes qui sont quand même assez
archaïques autrement dit peut-être que
les responsables politiques italiens ont
longtemps pensé que ce fameux
développement économique qui a bien eu
lieu en Italie hein comme partout
d'ailleurs en Europe occidentale aurait
pu faire p clité c'est mafia qui était
là déjà depuis longtemps ça pas été le
cas
pourquoi pourquoi c'est une grande
question c'est justement les les mafias
ont ont réussi à développer en fait on
dit que les mafias sont sont un facteur
de modernité pourquoi parce que cosana
Stra dans les années dans à la fin du
19e siècle elle est présente dans des
commerces qui sont en fait les commerces
les plus modernes les plus
internationaux c'est-à-dire le commerce
des
agrumes un commerce qui est déjà
transatlantique à l'époque donc c'est
quelque chose fondamentalement qui est
très moderne c'est l'internalisation des
activités mafieuses qui ont permis à
cette mafia de de se maintenir malgré le
dévelcom bien sûr et surtout la présence
dans le Nord alors il y a plusieurs
facteurs qui expliquent cette présence
mais effectivement le le fait qu'elle
soit ancrée on va dire dans la capitale
économique qui est mil an par le
blanchimement d'argent en particulier
c'est aussi un une des caractéristiques
de l'expansion mafieuse alors vous avez
écrit à l'occasion d'une interview
l'Italie c'est le pays qui a le meilleur
les meilleurs outils juridiques au monde
pour lutter contre la mafia autrement
dit l'État italien n'est n'est pas resté
sans rien faire et cette
fameux
outils juridique d'ailleurs est né bien
avant l'assassinat du Jules Falcon qu'on
a évidemment vu dans ce ce documentaire
de quoi il est fait cette cet outil
juridique qui serait le le plus puissant
d'Europe pour lutter contre les mafias
ce qu'il faut dire c'est que l'Italie
est le pays de la mafia et de
l'antimafia et que l'on doit déjà une
résistance populaire et citoyenne depuis
le début
euh les germes déjà de de de de de ces
outils juridiques c'est-à-dire que en
fait depuis 200 ans des gens se font
assassinés en Italie parce qu'il résiste
à la mafia un seul exemple au sortir de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale les mafieux
assassinent 20 30 40 syndicalistes en
quelques années rien qu'en Sicile il tue
la résistance sociale pour le compte des
grands propriétaires terrien donc euh
fautut déjà dire anticommuniste
notamment hein ça été dit dans ce film
d'ailleurs VO là les grands
propriétaires terriens évidemment par
aussi ils sont antiommuniste évidemment
mais il faut comprendre qu'il y a déjà
la société ensuite effectivement il y a
le droit très vite il y a des déjà des
maxi procès il y a plus d'un siècle en
Italie mais le problème par exemple
c'est que quand un un mafieux veut un
ancien mafieux veut témoigner il
n'arrive pas vivant au procès il est
mort donc par exemple on a un dispositif
depuis 91 dans la loi où aujourd'hui on
protège un ancien mafieux pour arriver
vivant au procès il fait de la prison
pendant 30 ans mais grâce à lui on
arrête les commanditaires des homicides
grâce à lui on confisque énormément de
bien donc vous voyez donc ça ce sont les
fameux repentis alors les fameux
repentis qu'on appelle collaborateur de
justice dans le droit italien vous avez
une série d'articles de loi très
importants notamment depuis 1982 un
délit d'association mafieuse qui permet
de condamner plusieurs personnes dont le
chef mafieux même s'il n'a pas participé
à l'homicide vous voyez ça c'est très
important la confiscation obligatoire
des avoirs car les mafieux détestent
perdre leurs biens ils peuvent encore
comprendre d'aller en prison ça fait
partie du job en revanche perdent leur
maison perdre leur compte en banque tout
ça ils détestent et cette confiscation
est extrêmement puissante alle est sans
condamnation pénale du propriétaire mais
on va pas rentrer dans les détails elle
permet de confisquer des des milliards
d'avoirs pour moi chaque année même s'il
y a toujours des discussions sur les
chiffres vous avez aussi des commissions
parlementaire antimafia c'est-à-dire que
en Italie les députés les sénateurs
peuvent enquêter sur le phénomène
mafieux il ils peuvent enquêter sur des
procès qui n'ont pas eu lieu ils peuvent
ils sont ils ont des pouvoirs
judiciaires ils peuvent aller prendre un
député quelqu'un qui ne veut pas qui ne
veut pas témoigner il peut ils peuvent
l'envoyer donc on arrive à faire des des
des affaires sur des scandales de
révéler des affaires c'est très
important pour lutter contre l'impunité
et enfin je voudrais parler c'est très
important ce que vous venez dire parce
que la mafia ça repose sur des
territoires ouais donc c'est la
reconquête des territoires permis aussi
cette législation vous nous amenez
d'ailleurs amener un un un paquet de de
biscuit explique nous là en fait la
confiscation c'est bien on prend au
mafieux et l'État a une logique il
revend le problème c'est qu'en Italie
quand on a essayé de revendre on s'est
rendu compte que c'est les mafieux qui
rachetaient ou tout simplement il n'y a
personne qui veut racheter au moment de
la mise aux enchères la peur la
connivence plein de choses fait que
personne ne va acheter le bien donc il
dépérit alors c'est un problème parce
que quand vous avez un hôtel qui
appartenait à la mafia il ferme les gens
disent avant ouais mais au moins moi
j'avais un boulot alors un boulot au
noir un boulot mal payé mais un boulot
alors grâce à l'association libéra et
une pétition d'un million de signatures
on a fait une loi on pas moi les
Italiens d'un million de signaturess ont
fait une loi qui permet de réutiliser le
bien confisqué c'est qu'on ne le vend
pas en Italie donc par exemple une terre
agricole confisquée l'État reste
propriétaire on fait un appel à projet
des jeunes et des moins jeunes se
mettent en coopérative et exploitent ça
donc aujourd'hui sur des terres par
exemple celui qui a tué le juge Falcon
sur ces terres il y a un groupe de
jeunes qui font du chiffre d'affaires
avec des contrats de travail avec
l'accès au crédit avec l'accès au soins
à la santé et ça ça change les
mentalités sur le territoire celui qui a
tué le juge Falcon il s'appelle Giovanni
bruska c'est lui qui a appuyé sur le
détonateur qui a fait sauter la bombe de
l'autoroute qui a tué ce fameux juge
Falcon sa femme ces tr/4s du corps
extrait du
documentaire in Sicilia alle ore 17:57 è
saltato in Aria un tratto d'autostrada
che porta dall'aeroporto a
Palermo le vittime sono Giudice Falcone
simbolo della lotta alla mafia insieme a
sua moglie Francesca morvillo e sette
agenti della loro
Scorta PAO Levi l' bien vu dans film
réuction la population il Mme une
réaction assez virulente de la
population une prise de conscience qui
s'est exprimé collectivement dans la
société italienne après cet assassinat
du du juge Falcon 2 mois après c'est
c'est le juge Borsellino qui lui-même
est assassiné bon il y a eu cette prise
de conscience tout de même dans la
population italienne la mafia les mafias
italienes on a l'impression que ça fait
partie du paysage italien d'ailleurs
tout comme la la chrétienté hein aussi
en Italie c'est le cas aujourd'hui
quelle est la la perception de la de ces
mafias par la population italienne après
cette cet assassinat du juge Falcon mais
oui ça disons il y a un avant et un
après le le 23 mai
1992 l'année dernière on a célébré ce
triste anniversaire 30 ans
depuis l'homicide de du juge Falcone et
de sa femme et et de tous les membres de
de son escorte sur l'autoroute qui
reliait l'aéroport de Palermo de
puntarisi à à la ville lui revenait de
Rome et et ça é é l'assassinat de de
trop pour la causanostra oui ça a été ça
a été un jour qui a marqué à jamais les
les
consciences de beaucoup d'Italiens on
peut faire un parallèle au niveau
mondial c'est un peu les Twin
Towers euh de l'Italie c'est-à-dire ces
images de de ces
voitures complètement détruites par
cette détonation qui avait été ordonné
par le parrain des parrains Totorina et
qui apparemment était sur la colline et
assisté de loin ce
barbare cette tuerie barbare et voilà a
marqué à jamais euh l'Italie ça a été
très très dur mais est-ce qu'elle fait
partie du paysage aujourd'hui encore la
mafia les mafia italienne est-ce qu'elle
font partie du paysage italien est-ce
que on peut dire qu'une majorité
aujourd'hui d'Italiens son
à 100 % derrière le pouvoir politique
pour lutter contre les mafias ou est-ce
que c'est plus compliqué que ça disons
que que le mouvement qui s'est déclenché
à la suite de l'homicide du juge Falcone
et de mois après en juillet de celui du
juge Borsellino nos deux héros nationaux
antimafia a été à la hauteur de la
barbarie de de ce même plus il y a eu
une réaction de la société civile très
très forte qui est partie de Palerme
donc des siciliens même qui ont commencé
à investir les rues à battre le pavé à
descendre dans les places tous ensemble
unis pour dire ça suffit ça suffit ça
suffit et ce mouvement a semé quelque
part des graines qui ensuite ont fleurri
et et il y a eu vraiment au moins pour
ce qui concerne la mafia
sicilienne l'État et le peuple parce que
l'État tout seul il peut rien faire sans
sans la base sans la société civile qui
se mobilise ensemble ils ont ont réussi
euh vraiment à à faire en sorte que que
cette mafia sicilienne causa nostra euh
euh perd ce ce pouvoir fou que qu'elle
avait aujourd'hui comme vous l'avez très
justement rappelé en début d'émission
malheureusement il n'existe pas
seulement une mafia en Italie même si le
cinéma nous nous explique toujours que
voilà il y a cette vision qui a été
aussi un petit peu alimentée par
Hollywood et cetera de la mafia
sicilienne cette mafia sicilienne du
Parin n'existe plus elle a été quasiment
batue en revanche il y a d'autres mafias
comme la mafia calabraise laandrangeta
ou la Camorra en dans la région de Naple
qui continue à vivre et et la mafia on
dit toujours c'est la pieuvre en fait
non la mafia est de plus en plus un
camaléon et il y a de plus en plus de de
col blanc qui les enfants des mafieux
aujourd'hui étudient dans les meilleures
universités d'Europe ils s'introduisent
de plus en plus dans l'économie disons
saine mais pour faire de sombres
affaires de recyclage de de d'argent et
cetera donc c'est une mafia qui est
devenue presque invisible on la voit
quasiment plus quand on on vit en Italie
c'est c'est désormais rare il y a
presque plus de règlements de compte à
Marseille qu'en Italie désormais mais
elle est là elle est bien présente ente
et surtout elle mobilise des quantités
d'argent immense avec l'Amérique du Sud
dans le trafic de drogue et en plein
d'autres activités on va revoir
justement quelques images que pe voir
les Italiens sur leur poste de télé he
dans les années 80 malheureusement image
de de cette
criminalité de pratiquement tous les
jours en
[Musique]
Sicile
ma s
préc la mafia commence à montrer son
visage le plus
sombre il avait en moyenne un meurtre
par jour on courit d'une scène de crime
à
l'autre parce que la lutte entre les
clans palerm et Coronis pour le pouvoir
éta sans merci alors ça c'était avant VI
de nous dire Paolo Levi il n'y a plus ce
genre de de de crime aujourd'hui chaque
jour à la à la télé face à l'opinion
italienne et il y en a une parmi ces
Mafi italiennes qui a semble-t-il tiré
les leçons de cette époque de la grande
époque de Cosan austral la mafia
sicilienne c'est la la mafia
calabraise qui elle a changé de méthode
et qui a rendu cette mafia caméléon pour
reprendre peut-être votre expression
tout à l'heure oui caméléon et même
tentaculaire parce qu'on a même les deux
images pour cumu voilà pour
l'ranget oui clairement laamranget à
profiter de que l'attention médiatique
soit focalisée sur cosananstra parce que
cananstra les massacres de Falcon et
Borsellino c'est une énorme erreur
stratégique puisqueaprès ça a déclenché
une répression outre le le mouvement
antimafia qui qui est né de après enfin
qui a pris de l'ampleur en tout cas
après ces ces deux
attentats on a on a vraiment une une
mafia calabrise qui va profiter de la
perte de légitimité de kananstra sur le
plan international pour justement à
cause des repentis qui du coup ben
collaborit avec la justice pour
justement aller tisser elle-même des
liens avec les les les narcotrafiquants
d'Amérique du Sud et du coup ouvrir un
canal direct hein pour euh pour
l'approvisionnement en drogue et c'est
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui l'andrangeta
est la mafia la plus importante en on va
dire euh en Europe mais aussi euh au
monde par rapport au trafic de cocaïne
c'est-à-dire c'est la première
importatrice de cocaïne en France en
France en Europe en 1991 les mafieux
calabrè se réunissent et disent les
homicides ça suffit parce queavant euh
ils tuaient autant que Cosanostra et
encore même plus dans un territoire
exigu il s'entretuai avec ce qu'on
appelle des FAAS donc des vengeances à
l'intérieur d'un même village les
familles qui s'exterminent tu as tué mon
frère je tue le tien bien donc je tue le
tien et cetera ils se réunissent et ils
disent les h homicide c'est fini alors
quand on fait un tableau des homicides
mafieux dans la province de RGO entre 91
et 98 il baisse spectaculairement pour
avoir aujourd'hui à peu près zéro
homicide j'ai toujours tendance à
exagérer quelques homicides restent mais
c'est extrêmement résiduel en même temps
elle décide d'arrêter l'enlèvement de
personne qui était une pratique barbare
qui faisait qu'on allait parfois
enfermer des enfants pendant 2 ans dans
un trou quand l'enfant sortait parce que
le papa avait payé la rançon l'enfant ne
savait plus marcher il avait grandi dans
un trou faut voir ces images la
hendrangeta arrête ça et qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait avec l'argent qu'elle a
tiré des enlèvements et d'autres
activités elle rentre massivement dans
le trafic de cocaïne qui est un trafic
qui en plus a cette particularité
d'avoir plus de plus-value une plusvalue
très importante que d'autres comme le
trafic de de cannabis et elle va devenir
très riche très solide aussi comme ça a
été dit parce que comme c'est une mafia
qui est faite en gros de lien de sang
pour y rentrer il faut être fils Dee ou
mari une fille de ou et cetera et bien
c'est plus difficile de témoigner contre
son père sa sœur sa sa mère et son frère
devant un tribunal et de l'envoyer à la
prison à vie donc pendant des dizaines
d'années il va y avoir presque pas de
repenti de collaborateur de justice dans
cette mafia qui va la rendre très
hermétique c'est un peu en train de
changer le mode est toujours le même
hein s'enrichir par l'activité légale en
l'occurrence c'est la cocaïne avec la
plusvalue que ça évidemment que ça
génère et puis euh
il faut surtout blanchir l'argent dans
l'économie légale c'est tout l'enjeu
maintenant de de la mafia alors tout ça
se fait de manière un peu invisible il
s'agit plutôt que de la criminalité faut
c'est plutôt la corruption semble le
mode opératoire pour blanchir cet argent
et corrompre qui les responsables
politiques les hommes d'affaires tous
ceux qui peuvent à un moment ou à un
autre blanchir cet argent oui
c'est-à-dire que tout ce qui va
caractériser une mafia c'est les liens
qu'elle va réussir à tisser avec le
pouvoir politique donc c'est pour ça que
l'andraangeta en particulier vu ses
liquidités a un énorme pouvoir de
corruption et elle s'attèle à reproduire
hors de la Calabre les mêmes mécanismes
qu'elle a mis en place en Calabre donc
parfois on a du contrôle du territoire
même dans Lombardie dans le Piémont dans
la en Ligurie en vallée d'aost hein donc
on peut retrouver les mêmes mécanismes
typiquement mafieux de contrôle du
territoire en ce qui concerne le
blanchiment évidemment le but c'est
d'infiltrer les appels d'offres pour
infiltrer les appels d'offres et ben il
faut corrompre des administrateurs
publics donc c'est pour ça que une une
mesure phare de l'arsenal législatif
italien c'est la dissolution des
administrations publiques c'est-à-dire
que le ministère de l'intérieur peut
peut décider de dissoudre pour
infiltration mafieuse une administration
publique la gouvernance d'un hôpital vu
que c'est une compétence régionale en
Italie voilà donc et il faut quand même
qu'on réfléchisse au fait que par
exemple 20 mille qui est la ville
frontière avec la France a été dissoue
pour pour infiltration mafieuse en 2012
donc donc l'andraangeta a réussi à
s'infiltrer dans énormément dans le
nord-ouest et ce qu'il faut préciser sur
l'andrangeta c'est vraiment qu'on a
découvert en 2010 qu'elle a opéré une
mutation structurelle c'est-à-dire
qu'avant on était sur une mafia de type
on va dire horizontale avec une une une
coexistence de plusieurs clans sur sur
selon des territoires différents
évidemment contrairement à causeanostra
d'ailleurs ù là il y a un Parin et c'est
c'est très verticale à l'époque elle
était verticale maintenant elle est elle
est plus revenu à l'état de fédération
mais l'andrangeta s'est verticalisé
c'est-à-dire qu'elle s'est doté d'un
organe de commandement pour justement
gérer comme une entreprise en fait qui a
des succursales un peu partout et qui
doit coordonner son ses affaires cette
fameuse andringeta fait l'objet
aujourd'hui d'un d'un maxi procès un
nouveau maxi procès hein il y a
452 accusés sur à l'occasion de ce
procès il a commencé en 2021 il est loin
d'être fini semble-t-il si on en croit à
la presse italienne et puis il y a eu un
énorme coup de filet il y y a quelques
mois du côté aussi de cette mafia
calabraise et pas seulement en Italie
d'ailleurs pour lustrer vos propos mais
sur le plan international Europol s'est
félicité de cette opération notamment du
côté allemand du côté des Pays-Bas mais
il y a aussi eu des interpellation chez
les fournisseurs hein les
narcotrafiquants qui sont situés en
Amérique du Sud est-ce que ça fait
parler ce ce futur et ce procès ce méga
procès actuel concernant cette fameuse
mafia calabraise qui est vous l'avez dit
hein la la plus puissante d'Europe
aujourd'hui et qui se situe donc en
calamre est-ce que ça fait parler dans
l'opinion publique est-ce que est-ce
qu'on en parle beaucoup de de de cette
lutte antimafia et anti dingetta non on
en parle jamais assez même c'est s'il y
a voilà une action vigoureuse de la part
des services de l'État le gouvernement
de georgeamelon l'actuel gouvernement
italien s'est récemment
affiché euh comme faire de lance de la
lutte à la mafia Meloni s'est s'est
rendu tout récemment dans ce qu'on
appelle les territoires perdus de la
République italienne qui sont notamment
dans la région de Naple où l'État est
malheureusement quasiment absent parce
que la criminalité et le crime organisé
voilà mis ses pions très très fort et au
moins disons d'un point de vue
symbolique d'image Meloni a promis une
guerre sans sans merci à au CRIM
organisé aux mafia après il faut voir si
dans on cela il y a une poursuite de la
politique déjà mise en place par ses
prédécesseurs on peut dire les choses
comme ça disons que dans la lutte aux
mafia euh disons le rôle le plus
important et déterminant a été donné par
je dirais la société civile et la
magistrature italienne des juges qui
souvent très seuls et isolé euh se sont
se sont vraiment mis contre ce système
et parfois au prix de la mort comme on
l'a vu avec donc il y a une forme de
consensus dans la classe politique
italienne aujourd'hui autour de cette
question de la lutte contre la mafia non
parce qu'il y a des infiltrations
mafieuses dans la politique même c'est
c'est tout le problème est là et et donc
la mafia comme vous le disiez elle est
partout elle s'infiltre dans les
conseils municipaux elle s'infiltre
peut-être même au Parlement il peut y
avoir des députés qui qui peuvent avoir
des relations de d'échange avec de vote
avec les mafieux donc elle est partout
donc c'est vraiment sinon ça serait plus
facile à résoudre et après il y a une
troisème dimension où la mafia est
désormais très très forte et où elle a
très bien réussi disons à évoluer c'est
les nouvelles technologies c'est
l'internet c'est les cryptoonnaaies
c'est le métavert il y a eu récemment
les une célébration pour les 30 ans de
de la DIA qui est le département de
lutte antimfia et le le chef de la DIA
qui a organisé une exposition itinérante
sur l'activité antimafia en Italie
disait justement que euh désormais le
recyclage euh d'argent et cetera tout
cela se passe aussi beaucoup euh sur
internet donc là ça devient encore plus
difficile à éradiquer à tracer et
éradiquer vous ti ajouter quelque chose
oui peut-être sur la classe politique
serait-elle encore on a envie de dire
grinée par les mafias italiennes parce
que la démocratie crétienne qui a tout
de même dominé la vie politique
italienne de après guerre a été a eu
cette réputation d'être sévèrement
gangriné et au sommet de cette de ce
parti qui qui a longtemps dirigé
l'Italie c'est toujours vrai alors et
ben il suffit de de de penser que Matteo
Messina dearo qui a été arrêté au mois
de janvier qui a été présenté en France
comme le parrain des parins alors que
enfin il est quand même c'était quand
même un chef important de la province de
trpani euh qui était le dernier des
corps Léonnais c'est-à-dire les derniers
de cette faction le dernier des
commanditaires des massacres de Falcon
Borsellino encore en liberté qui est
décédé il y a quelques jours formé par
Totorina qui lui-même a été le parrain
des parins ex exactement et ben lui son
référent politique c'était le secrétaire
à la défense du gouvernement Berlusconi
de 2001 à 2006 donc ça peut vous donner
une idée de du degré d'infiltration
mafieuse donc il faut pas alors
l'andrangeta et la camor c'est plus
particulier parce qu'elles ont plutôt
une tradition de de de représentant
politique à l'échelle locale alors que
kanstra a toujours eu comme comme
habitude de cultiver des liens avec des
représentants politiques locaux bien
évidemment mais aussi nationau alors sur
cette perméabilité oui entre la classe
politique italienne et et les mafias
italiennes et le milieu économique
italien vous avez envie de chos c'est la
définition des mafias comme l'avait dit
Charlotte moge mais et je viens donner
ici un autre mot du plus grand
spécialiste pour moi de la de la mafia
italienne en particulier de mafia
sicilienne ouberto Santino on parle de
bourgeoisie mafieuse c'est-à-dire qu'on
parle de mafieux c'est ceux qu'on le
pistolet qui tue ou qui ne tue plus en
effet qui corromp et cetera mais ils ne
sont rien sans un réseau de complicité
entrepreneur profession libérale avocat
vreux géomètre architectes politiciens
et leurs soldats qu'ils vont recruter
dans les quartiers populaires car
aujourd'hui ce sont des gamins de 14 ans
qui vendent la drogue dans les quartiers
populaires du zen à Palerme ou du
brancacho à Palerme c'est ces gens-là
forment un corps social un réseau qu'on
appelle la bourgeoisie mafieuse et qui
est la seule manière d'expliquer le fait
que la mafia continue malgré les
changements économiques
féodalité agricole vers propriété privée
agricole absence de démocratie vers
démocratie sansitaire ou suffrage
universel révolution industrielle le au
sortir de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
première république 2è République tous
les arsenals juridiques qui sont
extrêmement comme la dissolution des
conseils municipaux on a par exemple des
villes où ça fait trois fois depuis 1991
que le conseil municipal est dissou pour
infiltration mafieuse ce qui revient
c'est le fait que les élites les
professions libérales participent pas
tous de la complicité avec la mafia et
c'est ce qui fait sa force dans le
procès dont vous parliez en Calabre qui
est en fait à vibau Valencia dans le
nord de la la province de Calabre qui
n'avait pas été assez touché jusqu'ici
par la répression les deux faits pour
moi marquants de ce grand procès dont
vous parler c'est la présence de repenti
plus important qu'il n'y paraît et
Nicolas gratteri le magistrat antimafia
à l'initiative de ce procès qui est allé
chercher des complicités parmi la
société d'ambulance celui qui gère le
cimetière le conseiller municipal le
sénateur et là on voit la force et la
vitalité des mafias qui fait que elle
continue être puissante bien que l'État
italien est une vraie action contre elle
alors évidemment ça m'amène à à poser la
question finale est-ce que l'Italie va
bel et bien pouvoir se débarrasser une
fois pour toute de ces mafias et si oui
comment parce que alors est-ce qu'il
faut être optimiste modérément optimiste
pessimiste Paulo li c'est dur c'est
compliqué mais il faut être optimiste
parce que je pense que on l'a vu avec
kaanostra quand quand on yimé euh la
volonté le
courage qu'on qu'on mis dans cette lutte
le juge Falcone et le juge Borsellino il
y a des résultats le juge Falcone on
peut le citer avec cette phrase qu'il
avait dite il avait dit la mafia est un
phénomène humain et comme tout phénomène
humain il est destiné à mourir donc il
faut faire
confiance
dans dans le fait que que ce phénomène
sera indqu une bonne fois pour toutes
mais pour cela ça tient à quoi des
Incorruptibles comme l'a été l'ont été
les juges Falcon et borsalino oui et
aussi à l'exemplarité des des
Incorruptibles c'est-à-dire exactement
comme cette magnifique entreprise qui
fait des Talal ces petits biscuits salés
sur les terres confisquées à la mafia
voilà il faut surtout faire évoluer les
mentalités et des régions qui ont été
svies par la mafia depuis la guerre et
même de façon et donc si on fait évoluer
les mentalités après une fois qu'on rend
la la mafia Glo
rangarde les jeunes ne vont plus se
tourner vers elles mais elles vont se
tourner vers d'autres modèles plus sains
Virtuos et je suis persuadé que qu'on va
l' radiquer une bonne fois pour toutes
en Sicile comme en Calabre et partout
ailleurs dans le monde un certain
optimisme dans les propos tenus à
l'instant vous le partagez il faut oui
il faut il faut non il faut essayer
d'être optimiste maintenant je pense que
le plus grand danger peut venir des
politiques qui sont mises en place et
par exemple pour rebondir sur le
gouvernement Meloni une des mesures
qu'elle voulait mettre en place qui n'a
pas été mise en place heureusement ça a
été quand même la suspension des écoutes
téléphoniques ce qui pose problème dans
les enquêtes et des mesures qui ont été
proposés comme le fait de relever le
montant maximal pour les paiements en
cash c'est absolument catastrophique
parce que ça permet au mafia d'acquérir
des biens de de consommation courante de
luxe par exemple qu'elles vont ensuite
pouvoir revendre très facilement Mo j'ai
vu que
certains procureurs et juges antimafia
avvec qui parlait justement de ce projet
de loi c'était la fin du mois de juillet
dernier n'hésitez pas à dire que la
mafia était la grande gagnante de la
réforme de la justice entrepris par le
ministre Carl nordot il va passer ce
projet de loi c'est complètement
contradictoire avec les propos tenus
par la présidente du Conseil italien ces
histoires d'é cô téléphonique c'est pas
la première fois en gros il y a une
grande période profusion de loi fin 80
90 puis depuis les trois gouvernements
Berlusconi de 2001 il y a toujours eu
des lois pour finalement favoriser la la
loi la mafia par exemple on parle de
légalisation de la légalité par exemple
empêcher les faillites fruduleuses donc
du coup on peut fermer un commerce faire
une faillite frauduleuse toucher
l'assurance et rouvrir un commerce c'est
typiquement les mesures de
Berlusconi une autre chose le
gouvernement Berlusconi a donné 6 mois à
des repentis pour tout dire car ils
doivent tout dire he les repent italien
tous leurs avoirs et cetera le le
magistrat n'a pas le temps pendant 6
mois d'aller l'interroger si l'autre il
a commis 20 meurtres vous imaginez tout
ce qu'il faut voilà alors plus personne
ne veut collaborer avec la justice avec
de tels délais ce sont typiquement je
rejoins complètement Charlot Moch des
décisions de politique qui peuvent faire
que on va perdre l'espoir en en la
dernière en date madame mélonie elle
veut emprisonner les parents qui ont
laissé leurs enfant dehors à 14 ans
déscolarisé ou qui possède un revolver
c'est c'est typique de la pens mentalité
néofasciste de tout le monde MRE en
prison moi je m'attendais à ce qu'elle
lutte contre l'évasion fiscale les
milliards qui ne sont pas payés par les
Italiens et en particulier par les
entreprises et les grandes entreprises
italiennes parce que ces milliards
pourraient être injectés intelligemment
dans les services publics juste un
chiffre dans une ville qui a connu les
pires homicides de la mafia à casaldi
princichipe là où on a tué un prêtre on
n' pas tué un prêtre qu'en Sicile il y a
80 fonctionnaires pour faire tourner une
ville de 22000 habit
j'ai été élu local dans une ville de
22000 habitants en banlie parisienne on
a 500 fonctionnaires sur ces 500 vous en
avez plus de 250 ce sont des animateurs
qui s'occupent des gamins après l'école
on est bien content de les avoir le
mercredi après-midi et après l'école ben
l'Italie ils ont pas ça alors après
cette même ce même gouvernement Méloni
dit ah mais les enfants sont dans la rue
et tout mais c'est à elle de faire en
sorte que c'est ces politiques publiques
qui sont défaillantes en Italie soit
alimenté par de l'argent l'argent des
impôts ça sera le le mot de la fin
vraiment un grand merci à tous les trois
hein d'avoir participé à ce débat doc
consacré à la lutte contre les mafias
italiennes après le documentaire que
nous vous proposions aujourd'hui dans
cette émission vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtad des Badoc quelque chose me dit
qu'elle pourrait être nombreuse après
une émission comme celle-là j'espère
vous serez là pour réagir à ce que sont
ces réactions hein je compte sur vous
merci aussi à selmaali qui m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission puis moi je vous
donne rendez-vous tout simplement pour
un prochain débat doc euh même place
même heure et toujours avec son
documentaire et son débat à très
[Musique]
bientôt